just stop stop just stop doing it you're
going to drive me crazy
fine i'll just go sit at my desk and be
quiet sorry i annoyed you with my
[Music]
friendship
and i'm also sorry that a lot of people
here
for some reason think it's funny to
steal someone's personal property and
hide it from them
here's a little news flash it's not
funny in fact it's pretty freaking
unfunny
that was an overreaction
gonna hit the break room does anybody
want anything
bam you good yeah sure okay
yeah are you danger
jack danger it's actually pronounced
donger it's derived from a dutch word
meaning prudence in financial matters
oh jack donger
also cool have a seat i understand you
need a little help from the big boys
here at uspis hospice
yeah u.s postal inspection service
founded by benjamin franklin in 1772
undoubtedly a great man's greatest
accomplishment
are you aware that he he'll popularize
parmesan cheese in america
i am
[Music]
120 180 200. all right
oh thank you so much my daughter is
gonna love this
wow so glad i could help thanks merry
christmas you too
fa lalalalalala kaching so this is what
every day would be like if you hadn't
left
india
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
all right all right
now this just needs to cook for another
11 hours 32 minutes
and 60.
what the hell boyle you almost killed me
i'm not going out in a stool making
accident terry's going to die saving the
president
or jerry's never gonna die there's no
way we can clean this up by ourselves
we're gonna need help no no no no no no
no
what are you saying you know what she's
saying man
oh no mean marge so we're supposed to
come running to clean up your mess every
time you snap your
fat little fingers oh no no i actually
can't snap my fingers are always too wet
and i just thought since it's your job
oh i see
you cops think you're too good to clean
up after yourselves no
i can do it myself i'll just let's union
work how dare you try to steal our jobs
so where do we go from here well you
know the old saying
the only way to unclog a toilet is to
let it sit
you're a janitor you should know that's
not true boys
take out the trash oh great so you will
do it oh on the trash i get it okay that
makes more sense with your tone
love you marge all right sorry i called
you [ __ ]
i know you're not [ __ ] i know you are
you're a good guy
you too michael appears to be gay too
and yet he is my friend
i guess i do have a gay friend you know
what i'm gonna raise the stakes
you don't well i want you to watch this
and i want you to burn this into your
brains
because this is an image man i want you
people to remember
for a long time to come whenever you
come into the office i want you to think
about this we don't need to
yes we do what
oh oh oh
i did it
thank you thank you thank you see
i'm still here we're all still here
so you both have the mumps sorry to say
it's very contagious
you may not want to be her detective oh
it's cool i keep up to date on all my
vaccinations
i'm immune to stuff you've never even
heard of but not immune to braggadocio
anyhow over the next several hours you
will more than likely develop fever
aching fatigue doesn't sound too bad
also tart foods will cause intense jaw
pain so you may want to avoid sour
candies
what you may get painful greater like
swelling in your neck and often extreme
testicular discomfort
okay no doubt
due to the highly contagious nature of
the virus you will both be quarantined
to your houses for the next nine days
no nine days in isolation uh sir i'd be
happy to keep you company
we could watch the ten part nicholas
nickleby special on pbs
yeah there's a lot of long quiet
stretches i do love long quiet stretches
but
i don't want to be a burden plus i'm
getting used to being on my own
or we could be quarantined together
you know work the case yes
that actually sounds kind of fun kind of
it's gonna be the best week ever
i'm sorry did you not hear me say
extreme testicular discomfort yes we
heard you dr bad news doctor
sometimes when i'm down like this
it helps to sing the blues okay
[Music]
okay that's when you hear me what's
getting you down
no wait you supposed
no no no no no no no no
i used to work at a chop shop it was
chill decent hours
good benefits you could work while you
were high
which i never did cause that's
irresponsible anyway we did a lot of
work for this dude who stole
pontiacs the pontiac bandit okay
we called him bill but whatever no not
whatever the pontiac bandit is my
nemesis i've been chasing this guy
for eight years he's stolen hundreds of
cars all of them pontiacs
he's never left any evidence and he's
never been caught on camera the guy is a
ghost
super ghost he's a super ghost before we
go any further
i need to know if you're for real
describe the guy asian dude
maybe five eight spiky black hair rocks
in both ears
always wears a black suit it speaks with
a british accent like my girl dame judy
dench
i have impeccable taste so would you say
he looks sort of like
this is bill this is a composite sketch
from 10 interviews i've done
perfect match so all you know is what a
bunch of other mopes have said over the
years
anything else yeah
i know how to get in touch with them
doug judy
[Music]
[Music]
do
that's what nashua came up with that
sucks
wow that's what we came up with
well we can do better than that well the
main part of the ad has to stay the same
actually yeah it's the last five seconds
where we have
some leeway
the waving well no no you don't be
waving that was just what they did
you guys can be clapping they were
sitting
standing outside inside whatever i mean
this is where you really get to be
creative
okay okay everybody just calm down and
take a deep breath
what the hell is going on man yeah what
the hell is going on you got a
girlfriend
i know and she's fine thanks sorry i was
really planning on you being in the cab
during this okay that wouldn't make it
better
amy i'm just i'm not over you yet and i
would have never said anything because i
thought you and jake were happy but
after seeing you at jazz brunch
i think i might have been wrong don't
read into that that was a freak argument
we are very happy amy we have all the
same interests we have so much chemistry
when we're together it's like no matter
where we are in san diego i feel
compelled to tell you that san diego's
terrible
lay it all in the line amy santiago
will you marry me what okay really could
you stay in the cab i'm sorry i'll be
right there i promise or maybe i won't
what's your answer
you